madame la ministre monsieur le président
de la commission des finances monsieur
le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues comme chaque année il nous
revient d'examiner l'évaluation du
prélèvement sur recette au profit de
l'Union européenne présenté dans le
projet de loi de finances il s'agit d'un
exercice complexe de la mesure où le
moment le montant inscrit dans le projet
de loi de finan est seulement
prévisionnel les négociations entre le
Conseil et le Parlement européen autour
du budget européen pour 2024 ont touché
ces derniers jours à leur fin le 11
novembre dernier ces deux institutions
se sont accordées sur un montant de 189
milliards d'euros en crédit d'engagement
et de 143 milliards d'euros en crédit de
paiement le 20 novembre le Conseil a
adopté ce compromis et le Parlement
européen a fait de même hier comme il
est d'usage le gouvernement devrait
déposer prochainement un amendement
prenant en compte le montant du budget
européen pour la contribution française
je regrette pour la clarté de nos débats
que nous ne disposions pas aujourd'hui
d'une évaluation révisée du prélèvement
sur recette alors pourriez-vous madame
la ministre nous indiquer quand sera
déposé cet amendement pourriez-vous
d'ors et déjà nous indiquer quel serait
le mentant révisé de l'évaluation du
prélèvement sur recette en tout état de
cause et dans l'attente de cette
actualisation l'article 33 du projet loi
de finances évalue le montant du
prélèvement sur recette au profit de
l'Union européenne à 21,6 61 milliards
d'euros ce montant représente une
diminuation de une diminution de près de
2,287 milliards d'euros par rapport à la
prévision actualisée pour
2023 à mon sens cette baisse relative du
PSR qui s'explique par ces facteurs
conjoncturels ne saurait refléter une
stabilisation ou un ralentissement de la
contribution française à moyen terme le
montant du prélèvement sur recette
s'élèverait en moyenne à 26,9 milliards
de d'euros sur la période
2023-2027 je souigne toutefois que
l'évaluation du prélèvement sur recette
et de la contribution française au
budget de l'Union pour les années à
venir pourrait être affecté par les
négociations en cours sur la révision à
mi-parcours du cadre financier
pluriannuel 2021-2027 la Commission
européenne a ainsi présenté en joint
2023 ses propositions pour renforcer le
budget plurannuel de l'Union à hauteur
de 66 milliards d'euros ces positions
prévoient notamment la mise en place
d'une plateforme
européenne des technologies stratégiques
la Commission recommande également la
mise en place d'une facilité pour
l'Ukraine à hauteur de 50 milliards
d'euros dont elle n'indique pas qui en
apportera la
garantie certains étatsmembbres plus
frugo ont donc déjà fait part de leur
réticence à une telle augmentation du
budget de long terme de l'Union madame
la ministre pourriez-vous nous préciser
la position de la France dans les
négociations autour de la révision du
cadre financier pluriannuel à quelle
date espérez-vous parvenir à un accord
comment cette révision devrait-elle
affecter le affecter le montant de la
contribution française au budget de
l'Union la révision et parcours du cadre
financier devrait également
s'accompagner de l'adoption de nouvelles
ressources propres la Commission
européenne a formulé en ce sens des
propositions actualisées je ne peux
toutefois manquer de m'interroger mes
chers collègues sur le montant des
recettes de ces nouvelles ressources en
effet il n'y a pas il n'est pas certain
qu'elles soit suffisante pour couvrir
les BES besoin de financement du
remboursement du plan de relance et de
ses intérêts d'une part et du Fond
Social pour le climat d'autre part je
rappelle que l'engagement financier de
la France au titre de Next Generation eu
est de l'ordre de 75 milliards d'euros à
défaut d'adoption de ces nouvelles
ressources signifieraient ainsi un
surcroix de 2,5 milliards d'euros
annuels pour la contribution française
par ailleurs cette évaluation ne prend
pas ne tient pas compte des différences
garanties que la France serait
susceptible d'accord
au soutien de l'Ukraine en implication
de l'article 46 à 48 du présent projet
de loi de financeces il serait
opportun madame la ministre au vu des
engagements pris par la France de
disposer d'une évaluation précise des
montants que la France serait
susceptible d'être appelé à verser à
l'Union à moyen terme au-delà du seul
prélèvement sur recette pour terminer je
tenais à interroger le gouvernement
c'est la dernière sur l'avancée des
versements du plan de relance
européen pour rappel la France a déposé
une deuxième demande de paiement le 31
juillet 2023 pour un temps montant de
10,3 milliards d'euros la Commission a
publié un projet de décision de
validation le 17 novembre madame la
ministre à quelle date pensez-vous que
la France pourrait percevoir ce nouveau
versement en guise de conclusion mes
chers collègues lors de l'examen de
l'article 3 de l'article 33 par la
commission le 31 octobre la commission
des Finances avait proposé son adoption
sans modification je recommande donc
l'adoption sans modification de cet
article
merci merci chers collègues la parole
est à présent à Madame Christine Lavarde
au nom de la commission des Affaires
européenne pour 3
[Applaudissements]
minutes madame la ministre je vous prie
d'excuser l'absence du président Rapin
qui se trouve actuellement en
Allemagne nous sommes devant un paradoxe
la contribution de la France au titre du
prélèvement sur recette au profit de
l'Union européenne va diminuer l'année
prochaine pourtant dans le même temps
nous savons que le budget de l'Union va
fortement monter en puissance dans les
années à venir financer les transitions
écologiques et numériques les
conséquences de la guerre en Ukraine
dans un contexte de forte inflation et
de taux d'intérêt élevé avec en plus le
devoir de rembourser l'emprunt européen
levé aux sorties de la pandémie tout
cela impose que la trajectoire du budget
européen ne puisse qu'être qu'à la
hausse à mi-parcours du cadre financier
pluriannuel
2020-2027 la Commission propose déjà de
le rallonger de 66 milliards d'euros
parallèlement elle met sur la table de
nouvelles ressources propres mais force
de constater que le compte n'y est pas
ce nouveau train de ressources propres
n'est en réalité qu'un seul wagon la
création d'une ressource stat
temporaire fondé sur l'excédent brut
d'exploitation des entreprises surtout
cette ressource propre n'en est pas une
il s'agit plutôt d'une nouvelle forme de
contribution nationale à l'image de la
ressource RnB ou de la contribution
plastique il y a urgence sans nouvelles
ressources propres les dépenses
supplémentaires de l'Union alourdiront
mécaniquement les contributions des
États-membres selon la Cour des comptes
en l'absence de concrétisation de
nouvelles ressources propres la
contribution de la France augmenterait
de 2,5 5 milliards d'euros par an
pendant 30 ans à partir de 2028 et
attention ce n'est qu'une projection à
UE constante or il est peu probable que
l'UE reste à 27 si longtemps nous ne
pouvons ignorer qu'un élargissement à 9
nouveaux États-membres augmenterait le
budget européen de plus de 20 %. madame
la ministre quels en serait donc
l'impact sur la contribution française
comment la France envisage-t-elle
durablement le financement du projet
européen et où en sont les négociations
sur les ressources propres s'il nous
faut voir loin nous devons aussi veiller
aujourd'hui au bon usage du budget
européen or sur ce sujet la Cour des
comptes européennes s'est récemment
montré très critique pour la 4e année
consécutive elle a émis une opinion
défavorable sur la légalité et la
régularité des dépenses de l'Union en
2022 elle estime le taux d'erreur des
paiements à 4,2 % des dépenses
s'agissant du plan de relance et de
facilité pour la reprise et la
résilience le fameux FFR elle a émis une
opinion avec réserve soulignant que 11
des 13 subventions versées aux
États-membres dans ce cadre présentaient
des problèmes de
régularité lutter contre ces
irrégularités s'impose avant même
d'envisager de nouvelles hausses
d'autant plus qu'ell se répète d'année
en année comment expliquer ces trop
nombreuses irrégularités serait-ce la
trop grande complexité des règles
d'attribution des aides européennes
madame la ministre que propose le
Gouvernement sur ce
sujet dans la suite du débat la parole
est est à notre collègue Florence
blatrix contta pour le groupe socialiste
écologique et républicain pour 6
minutes monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
permettez-moi tout d'abord de souligner
l'importance de la participation
française au budget de l'Union
européenne en tant que deuxème
contributeur net la France assume une
responsabilité significat
au sein de l'Union pour l'exercice
budgétaire 2024 la contribution
française connaît une légère baisse de 4
milliards cette diminution découle
principalement d'un décalage dans
l'exécution des crédits de la de la
politique de cohésion des effet de
l'inflation sur l'évolution du RNB des
États-membres et de l'augmentation des
droits de douane liés à la reprise du
commerce internationale malgré cette
baisse ponctuelle la contribution
française connaît une augmentation
constante depuis 20 ans ce constat
m'amènera d'ailleurs à évoquer la
nécessité d'accroître l'autonomie
budgétaire de l'Union en cherchant de
nouvelles ressources mais d'abord cette
discussion sur la contribution française
au budget de l'Union doit inévitablement
nous amener à évoquer la question
pressente de la révision du cadre
financier pluriannuel de l'UE qui sera
révisé à mi-parcours les récents
événements tels que la guerre en Ukraine
la hausse significative de l'inflation
des taux d'intérêt souigne la pression
croissante sur le budget de l'UE et la
complexité de la planification à moyen
terme la Commission européenne
confrontée à cette réalité a présenté en
juin dernier une proposition de révision
du cadre financier incluant 66 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires cependant nous
regrettons que cette proposition ne soit
pas à la hauteur des besoins n'intègre
pas suffisamment les nouvell réalité
telles que les implications de l'IRA
américaine est la nécessité d'un soutien
massif à la transition écologique il est
impératif que l'Europe ne fléchisse pas
dans la course à la décarbonation
qu'elle investisse non seulement dans
l'innovation dans la recherche mais
qu'elle amplifie également la production
à grande échelle des technologies
existantes la révision du cadre
financier pluriannuel doit être
ambitieuse prenant pleinement en compte
les enjeux de la des transitions
écologique et de compétitivité cette
nécessité soutenue par les conclusions
du GC est indéniable la transition
écologique coûtera cher mais bien moins
que l'inaction malheureusement lors du
dernier Conseil européen les 27 ont
exprimer leur opposition à cette
rallonge de 66 milliards d'euros
demandés par la commission privilégiant
plutôt l'idée de de redéploiement cette
position nous inquiète et soulligne la
nécessité de développer de nouvelles
ressources pour l'Union européenne dans
la dans cette perspective les
propositions de nouvelles ressources
telles que le marché carbone européen le
mécanisme d'ajustement carbone aux
frontières le pilier 1 de l'accord sur
la fiscalité internationale du G20 de
l'OCDE représente une avancée cruciale
pour renforcer les moyens financiers de
l'Union cependant il n'est pas
acceptable que le Conseil retarde toute
décision sur ce paquet pourtant proposé
par la Commission européenne il y a
presque 2 ans de même nous nous
réjouissons de la proposition d'une
nouvelle ressource statistique
temporaire fondé sur l'excédent brut
d'exploitation des entreprises il s'agit
pour nous d'une première étape
significative vers la réalisation de ce
qui pourrait constituer un impôt
européen pour les sociétés même si pour
l'instant c'est une nouvelle
contribution des états il est impératif
d'aller plus loin plus rapidement dans
cette direction c'est la position du
groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain qui propose en outre la
taxation des profits exceptionnels des
entreprises au-delà du secteur de
l'énergie la mise en place d'un ISF vert
européen et une augmentation du taux de
la taxes sur les multinationales enfin
mes chers collègues il est essentiel
d'évoquer la nécessité de la révision
équilibré du pacte de stabilité et de
croissance qui soutiennent les
investissements publics dans les
transitions climatique et numérique tout
en nassouplissant les contraintes
budgétaires imposées aux États-membres
cette révision doit impérativement
intégrer des règles budgétaires
transparentes prenant en considération
la spécificité des situations nationales
et j'insiste sur la transparence hein
sans une transparence adéquate de la
part de la Commission européenne il sera
difficile en réalité d'évaluer la
nouvelle méthode de calcul annoncée
notamment d'évaluer la prise en compte
des spécificités
nationales de plus il est crucial de
garantir la possibilité enfin pour nous
c'est vraiment important d'exclure
certains investissements du solde
structurel c'est ce que nous proposons
s'agissant des investissements dans la
transition écologique en conclusion mes
chers collègues l'Union européenne se
trouve à la croisée des chemins elle est
appelée à faire des choix décisifs ne
rien changer reviendrait à renoncer à
notre idéal européen alors que relever
le défi du financement des les enjeux de
demain et le seul chemin pour répondre
au doutes d'une partie de notre
population il est impératif que la
France assume son rôle moteur sans céder
au frugo ces états qui austéritaires qui
freinent les dépenses nécessaires à la
compétitivité à la transition écologique
dégager de nouveaux financements est
désormais une nécessité absolue pour
préparer l'avenir de notre continent à
ma place l'en dernier mon collègue
Patrice jolie voquit la situation John
Mony qui affirme que l'Europe ne se
construit qu'au fil des crises une fois
de plus nous sommes témoins de cette
réalité et nous devons tirer les
conséquences sur euh en accord avec les
engagements de la France notre groupe
votera en faveur de cet article je vous
remercie merci la parole est à présent
notre collègue Martha citrac pour le
groupe les républicains pour 4
[Applaudissements]
minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues le
prélèvement sur les recettes du budget
général de l'État en faveur de l'Union
européenne est constitué de plusieurs
composantes une ressource TVA qui
correspond à un prélévement de 03 % sur
une assiette harmonisée pour tous les
États-membres une contribu calculé sur
le revenu national brut et une nouvelle
ressource créée en 2021 sur les
emballages plastiques non recyclés dit
ressource plastique en 2023 le montant
du PSR UE était de 24,6 milliards
d'euros pour 2024 il est estimé en
légère diminution à hauteur de 21,6
milliards d'euros en ajoutant au PSR les
ressources propres traditionnelles que
constituent les droits de douane
collectés directement au profit de
l'Union européenne l'ensemble constitue
la contribution de la France au budget
européen à titre d'information 2023 les
ressources propres traditionnel
représentai environ 3 milliards d'euros
depuis
2010 seul le psrue fait formellement
l'objet d'un vote au Parlement c'est le
sens même de cet article 33 du PLF 2024
le budget européen pour 2024 est donc le
4e du cadre financier pluriannuel
portant sur les années
2021-2027 ce cas cadre pluriannuel a
prévu un plafond global de dépensees de
plus de 1200 milliards d'euros en crédit
d'engagement sur 7 ans il doit notamment
permettre à l'UE de répondre aux
conséquences économiques et sociales de
la pandémie de covid-19 grâce au plan de
relance européen next generation eu d'un
montant de plus de 750 milliards d'euros
il dote également l'Union européenne de
moyens d'action élargie en matière de
politique étrangère ce qui s'avère
précieux dans l'aide apportée à
l'Ukraine depuis bientôt 2 ans nous
sommes donc réunis aujourd'hui pour
discuter de ce budget européen mais la
marge d'action des parlements nationaux
et vous l'imaginez bien faible sauf à
vouloir casser la baraque européenne
évidemment nous voterons cet article 33
tant l'exercice est convenu cependant
cela ne ne dispense pas de certaines
remarques avec 24 milliards d'euros en
2023 la France est derrière l'Allemagne
le deuxème contributeur d'un budget de
l'Union européenne de près de plus de
180 milliards d'euros sans rien remettre
en question de nos engagements auprès de
nos partenaires européens il est permis
de s'interroger sur le ratio
coût-bénéfice de notre contribution ce
débat est ancien comporte évidemment de
nombreux biais j'en suis consciente
notre pays fait partie des plus
importants contributeurs nets dans la
période d'endettement et de déficit
record que nous traversons un delta donc
de 10 milliards d'euros entre le montant
que nous donnons par rapport à celui que
nous recevons n'est pas tout à fait
anodin il n'est pas anodin car il faut
tenir compte du contexte national et de
l'inflation il est perçu par le
contribuable français comme une sorte de
double peine au niveau national àommet
de taxes et peinant à en voir les effets
au niveau européen large contributeur
net pour des retombées somm toutes peu
visibles mais nos concitoyens se
questionnent sur le sens d'une telle
disparité il faut être non seulement
capable de l'entendre mais aussi de
l'expliquer un point positif cependant
le soutien que nous recevons de l'Union
européenne est investi dans deux
spécificités françaises qui convient de
défendre d'une part les aides de la PAC
versé à hauteur de 9 milliards d'euros
par an jusqu'en 2027 première puissance
agricole de l'Union européenne il est
essentiel que la France en soit la
première bénéficiaire c'est un soutien
vital pour nos agriculteurs je me
permets d'insister sur ce point car ne
l'oublions pas lorsqu'il s'agira
d'aborder le dossier de l'élargissement
d'autre part les aides apporté aux rupes
régions ultrapériphériques que sont nos
territoires d'outrem la Commission s'est
en effet engagé dans un partenariat
stratégique renouvelé et renforcé avec
les rupes il s'agit d'un soutien
substantiel la France détenant le
deuxième espace maritime mondial via ces
territoires ultramarins chers collègues
dans un exercice assez convenu il nous
sera donc demandé de voter cet article
33 en européenne convaincu je le voterai
néanmoins restons ensemble attentif aux
interrogations légitime de nos
concitoyens et je vous remercie merci
chers collègues la parole est à présent
à Monsieur emric durx pour 3 minutes
pour les sénateurs ne figurant sur la
liste d'aucun
[Musique]
groupe monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre chers collègues la droite et la
gauche sont deux détaillants qui ont le
même grossiste l'Europe c'est ainsi que
s'exprimait Philippe sgin à propos de
l'Union européenne lui qui fustigait
l'abandon de la souveraineté nationale
pourtant consubstantielle de notre
nation au profit d'une putative
souveraineté européenne abandon
accompagné avec hardardeur par la gauche
et la droite depuis 30 ans nous
discutons ce jour de la participation de
la France au budget de l'Union
européenne participation injuste à tous
les égards qui s'élève donc à 21,6
milliards pour 2024 injuste car la
France a toujours payé Ruby sur ongle sa
participation incité à le faire sans
contrepartie aucune par les dirigeants
les plus européistes du continent à
alors que le Royaume-Uni l'Allemagne
l'Autriche la Suède les Pays-Bas ou
encore le Danemark ont bénéficié pendant
des décennies de rabais ou de rabaetis
sur le rabetis simplement parce qu'ils
étaient gouvernés par des politiques
soucieux de leur intérêt propre laissant
reposer sur la France le poids de
l'utopique construction européenne ce
sont des milliards que les contribuables
français ont payé et continuent à payer
pour les autres alors que nous sommes
déjà le pays le plus taxé au monde
injuste car la contribution nette de la
France au seul budget de l'Union
européenne de 2000 à 202 aura coûté plus
de 175 milliards d'euros à notre pays
c'est l'équivalent du coût de
construction d'une dizaine de PA dont
nous aurions tant besoin aujourd'hui
après que l'État a laissé détruire notre
filière nucléaire pour faire plaisir au
vert c'est aussi l'équivalent d'une
bonne 6antaine de gros hôpitaux ou d'une
cinquantaine de porte-avion nucléaires
pire l'argent que l'Union européenne
daigne nous redonner est fléché et nous
ne pouvons pas l'utiliser comme nous le
souhaitons c'est donc la double peine
qui a été évoquée qui nous est appliqué
l'Union européenne nous coûte un pognon
de dingue pour des résultats économiques
par ailleurs médiocrees 175 milliards
d'euros après que nous a apporté l'Union
européenne notre agriculture se
pororta-elle mieux notre accès 10
privilégi au marché unique a-t-il
protégé nos entreprises ou a-t-il
empêché les délocalisations ou le
dumping social provoqué par les
travailleurs détachés notre sécurité aux
frontières est-elle mieux assuré 175
milliards d'euros après il est temps de
faire le bilan et il est sans appel pour
le C des européistes BA et pourtant
cette contribution ne va faire
qu'augmenter dans les années à venir en
raison de deux facteurs d'une part
l'intégration probable et souhaité par
le président Macron et les instances
européennes de nombre de pays des
Balcans et du Caucase ces adhésions
feront nécessairement augmenter la note
pour la France comme après l'entrée des
pays de l'Est d'autre part le départ
définitif de Londres ainsi que le
remboursement du plan de relance covid
initié par les 27 en 2020 et qui a été
mal négocié pourrait alourdir la note
pour notre pays à partir de 208 depuis
de de plus de 2,5 milliards d'euros par
an pendant 30 ans selon la Cour des
comptes bref il faut mettre fin à ce
tonneau des danaïes Européens sans cesse
comblés par le contribuable français il
faut une contribution plus juste et plus
respectueuse de nos intérêts ce que
votre gouvernement est incapable
d'assurer vous pourrez compter sur les
sénateurs du rassemblé national pour
défendre l'intérêt de notre pays et les
prochaines élections européennes feront
office de juge de paix sur la question
vox populi voxdi
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Emmanuel Capu pour le groupe les
indépendants pour 4
minutes monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur spécial
monsieur le président de la commission
des finances mes chers collègues la
participation de la France au budget de
l'Union européenne pour 2024 est en
forte baisse par rapport à 2023 plus de
3 milliards d'euros avant notre examen
la justification conjoncturelle ne nous
a pas échappé la France c'est environ 18
% des contributions des États-membres
nous sommes contributeurs nets là encore
je ne vous apprends rien en revanche je
fais le vœux qu'un jour nous puissions
quantifier ce que l'Union européenne
nous apporte en retour de manière
directe et indirecte cela tordrait le
coup à bien des idées reçues qu'on vient
d'entendre je le répète à chaque étude
de l'article du PL LF relatif à la
contribution française de l'Union
européenne l'Union européenne n'est pas
une option mais un levier indispensable
pour répondre aux enjeux face à nous et
ils sont nombreux est-ce que la révision
du cadre financier pluriannuel 2021-2027
nous fait craindre des hausses de
contribution pour les prochaines années
oui comme tout le monde dans cet
hémicycle est-ce que nous accueillons
favorablement le nouveau panier de
ressources propres proposé par la
Commission européenne en juin dernier
dont l'excédent BR d'exploitation des
entreprises oui et nous souhaitons des
ressources propres renforcé en prévision
des prochains efforts que l'Union
européenne va devoir fournir est-ce que
l'augmentation des Rabet d'autres États
membres au premier rang desquels
l'Allemagne nous indigne c'est une
troisième fois oui et la solution n'est
certainement pas d'obtenir nous-même un
Rabet mais plutôt de convaincre les
autres d'abandonner les leurs quand on
est européen on l' entièrement pas au
Rabet pour le groupe Les Indépendants la
réponse à toutes ces questions c'est
l'Union européenne j'évoquais la
solidarité l'an dernier cette année je
pense que le mot qui devrait qualifier
notre action d'Européen c'est puissance
car si nous acceptons de contribuer il
est temps de se poser la question de
pourquoi que décidons-nous de faire en
européen c'est à nous et seulement à
nous de donner l'impulsion à l'Europe à
ce
titre je nous invite tous à suivre avec
attention le prochain Conseil européen
de décembre le menu est appétissant
entre autres la renégociation du CFP on
parle d'une hausse de 66 milliards ou
encore la question de l'élargissement et
de la réforme de notre système la
Commission européenne vient de se
prononcer en faveur de l'ouverture
formelle des négociations d'adhésion
avec l'Ukraine sommes-nous prêts mes
chers collègues au-delà de la
restauration de notre indépendance de la
reconstruction de nos industries il va
falloir que l'Union européenne se en
puissance les conflits récents à nos
portes nous y exhortent nous devons
impérativement réformer l'Union
européennes les peuples européens
méritent mieux soyons enfin ce que nous
devons être et que notre contribution y
participe mes chers collègues merci la
parole est à notre collègue Jean-Michel
Arnaud pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste pour 6
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues l'article 33 du
projet de loi de finances pour 2024
porte donc sur la contribution de la
France au budget de l'Union européenne
ce prélèvement sur recette du budget de
l'État représente un montant de plus de
21 milliards d'euros auquel il faut
ajouter les droits de douane ces
derniers étant estimé à 3 milillards 112
millions la contribution française
serait donc de 23 m Milard et quelques
pour l'année 2024 si nous pouvons
constater une baisse relative de cette
contribution entre 2023 et 2024 il
s'agit en réalité d'une stabilisation
conjoncturelle en vue de futurs
engagements financiers tout en sachant
que notre pays demeure le deuxième
contributeur comme C a été rappelé
derrière l'Allemagne néanmoins ces
données en apparence intéressante ne
doivent pas occulter certains facteurs
politiques et économiques favorisant la
hausse systématique voire systémique de
la contribution française par rapport au
cadre pluriannuel finan
précédent il y a par exemple les
difficultés d'analyser l'impact de la
nouvelle taxe plastique mise en place en
2021 ou encore les effets des différents
Rabet négociés par cinq États membres
l'Allemagne les Pays-Bas la Suède
l'Autriche et le Danemark ce dernier
point doit particulièrement faire
l'objet de notre attention dans une
époque où l'idée de solidarité
européenne est usée à tout va ces
dérogations budgétaires tentent toujours
à favoriser la défiance voire la
m-entente entre les États-membres le
budget de l'Union européenne pour
l'année 2024 s'élève quant à lui à 142,6
milliards d'euros en crédit de paiement
et à
189,4 milliards d'euros en crédit
d'engagement pour Rael celui-ci
s'inscrit dans un cadre pluriannuel fixé
pour 7 ans il permet de prévoir à moyen
terme là où l'Union doit concentrer ses
efforts et ses dépenses et fixe aussi
les montants maximums sur lequel l'Union
européenne peut s'engager chaque année
pour financer ses politiques pour la
période
2021-2027 ce plafond été fixé à 1074
milliards d'euros et s'accompagne d'un
plan de relance inédit de 750 milliards
d'euros dénommé next generation eu afin
de répondre aux conséquences économiques
de la pandémie du covid-19 c'est dans ce
contexte que la Commission européenne a
présenté le 20 juin 2023 ses
propositions pour une révision à
mi-parcours du cadre financier pluannuel
cette proposition s'explique en partie
par la hausse des dépenses découlant du
conflit ukrainien par la tendance
également de l'inflation que nous
connaissons sur l'ensemble de l'Europe
mais également par les besoins en
matière de transition énergétique et
numérique pour tenir compte de ces
effets la Commission a proposé une
révission à la hausse du cadre financier
pluriannuel de l'ordre de 66 milliards
d'euros en crédit d'engagement sur la
période
2024-2027 ces nouveaux crédits devraient
permettre de financer notamment deux
objectifs une nouvelle facilité pour
l'Ukraine absolument nécessaire conten
l'enlisement de ce conflit face à la
Russie et une plateforme européenne des
technologies stratégiques
le premier dispositif vise à participer
à la reprise à la reconstruction à la
modernisation de l'Ukraine qui subit
toujours les assauuts de l'armée russe
dans l'est de son territoire notre
groupe Union centriste réaffirme bien
naturellement le soutien indéfectible de
la France et de l'ensemble des Français
à l'Ukraine contre l'agresseur russe
quant à la plateforme européenne des
technologies stratégiques elle poursuit
l'objectif de décarboner le secteur
industriel pour atteindre la neutralité
climatique de l'Union européenne à
l'horizon 2050
comme tout exercice budgétaire le budget
de l'Union européenne pour 2024
s'accompagne également d'un lot de défi
à relever pour commencer l'instauration
de nouvelles ressources propres est un
impératif absolu la Commission a
présenté en juin dernier une proposition
relative à la nouvelle génération des
ressources propres toutefois il n'est
pas certain que les recettes tirées de
ces dites ressources soi suffisantes
pour couvrir à la fois le remboursement
du plan de relance et et de ses intérêts
et l'abandement du Fond Social pour le
climat absolument nécessaire pour
accompagner la transition énergétique et
climatique je souhaite insister
particulièrement sur ce point l'objectif
de réduction de 55 % des émissions dans
l'Union européenne d'ici 2030 se
financera par l'affectation d'une partie
des recettes des nouvelles ressources
propres à un fond social pour le climat
ces dernières vont donc être
parallèlement fléchées vers deux
initiatives ambitieuses c'est pourquoi
la viabilité budgétaire et financière de
cette architecture budgétaire doit
appeler la vigilance de notre haute
assemblée en adoptant un prisme plus
global le budget de l'Union européenne
doit être un outil au service des
aspirations européennes notamment deux
d'entre elles la première renforcer la
cohésion entre les États récemment la
Commission a rappelé à l'ordre quatre
États membres dont la France en raison
du niveau élevé des dépenses publiques
constaté dans les comptabilités de
chacun de ces états le respect des
règles budgétaires communes est un des
piliers de la solidarité européenne mais
cette solidarité s'entretient également
par une convergence politique dans les
secteurs stratégiques or a-t-
d'illustration la nouvelle Pâque a posé
les fondations d'une agriculture
diversifiée entre les États source de
disparité économique tout en
s'inscrivant dans une réduction de la
production agricole alors que la
souveraineté alimentaire s'avère être un
enjeu stratégique pour l'avenir de nos
populations en Europe il y a donc encore
du travail bien que dans d'autres
domaines les efforts produisent des
résultats je pense notamment à la future
réforme du marché de l'électricité comme
le disait Jacques Delor après la crise
des subprimes après les pompiers l'Union
européenne attend les architectes pour
l'instant les seuls architectes que l'on
constate c'est la mon des populismes et
le dernier résultat constaté hier à
l'occasion des élections au Pays-Bas
démontre le danger qui qui guête à nos
portes et qui risque de fragiliser de
fracturer l'Union européenne il est donc
temps queà l'occasion de ce débat nous
puissions réaffirmer fortement nos
convictions européennes car
contrairement à ce que j'ai entendu par
l'un des orateurs au sein de cette Haute
Assemblée l'Union européenne a garanti
la paix et je peux vous dire que la paix
c'est extrêmement précieux quand on voit
les difficultés constatées en Ukraine
face à l'agression russe et quand on
voit les difficultés au proches
Moyen-Orient ne l'oublions jamais je
vous
remercie merci la parole est à présent à
notre collègue Jacques
fernck pour 4
minutes merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre monsieur le président
de commission chers collègues la
contribution de la France au budget de
l'UE représente un triple enjeu tout
d'abord elle intervient au moment de la
révision à mi-parcours du cadre
financier pluriannuel elle intervient
aussi si avant les élections européennes
enfin elle doit prendre en compte le
retour annoncé de règles du pacte de
stabilité et de croissance ce débat
vital autour du prélèvement européen nos
collègues députés on le sait en ont été
privés muselés par le 493 mon groupe
votera pour cet article 33 notre
engagement européen reste résolu ceci
étant dit le débat d'aujourd'hui doit
nécessairement prendre en compte les
enjeux que j'ai énoncé l'Union a été
confronté à des crises imprévisibles la
pandémie l'inflation la remontée des
taux d'intérêt l'approvisionnement
difficile en énergie et évidemment la
guerre en Ukraine ces crises lui ont
certes permis de se renforcer elles ont
par exemple abouti au plan de relance et
à un endettement commun résolu mais ces
avancées reposent sur un financement
instable précaire les contributions
nationales même un Européen résolu peut
se demander où va l'Union et avec
l'élargissement quels choix seront
nécessaires pour faire évoluer les
institutions le budget nous serons
bientôt peut-être 36 les défis à relever
sont immenses notamment climatiques seul
un projet ambitieux sera capable de les
relever mais ce projet ambitieux il a un
coout on ne peut pas attendre toujours
plus de l'Union européenne sur la santé
sur le soutien à l'Ukraine sur le climat
la réindustrialisation les politiques
social tout cela à budget constant c'est
vrai la France ne bénéficie d'aucun Raba
elle est même le principal financeur des
rabaiss des autres on sait aussi que
lorsqu'on rapporte l'ensemble des
politiques d'aide européenne à la
population de chaque pays la France se
situe à la 20 3e place on sait également
que le Fond européen d'aide au plus
démunis est sous-consommé en France
alors qu'il y a urgence pour les restos
du cœur pour les banques alimentair
notamment dans un contexte où de
nombreux ménages peinent à joindre les
de bouts on comprend que notre
contribution importante au budget
européen puissent faire grincer des
dents non la capacité budgétaire de
l'Union ne peut pas reposer sur
l'essentiel pour l'essentiel sur des
contributions national instable
impopulaire et sans cesse marchander une
autre voie est possible et elle est plus
que nécessaire alors que d'orénavant ça
vient d'être dit quasi chaque élection
en Europe enregistre des avancées de
l'extrême droite anti-européenne pour
enrayer cette déconstruction de l'Union
qui avance il faut développer les
ressources propres de l'Union j'abonde
dans le sens aujourd'hui elle représente
moins de 20 % du budget européen contre
plus de 70 % pour les contributions des
États avec les accords de libre échange
depuis des décennies la part des
ressources douanières a considérablement
diminué la France aurait tout à gagné de
l'AC iation des ressources propres nous
sommes le pays dont le solde net c'est
le plus creusé cela n'ira pas en
s'arrangeant certes notre contribution
pour 2024 à baiss ne s'élèverait qu'à
21,6 milliards mais cette légère baisse
on l' dit n'est que temporaire notre
contribution sera amenée à augmenter ces
prochaines années au regard du cadre
financier pluriannuel notre enveloppe au
titre du plan de relance européen a
diminué de 2 milliards tandis que le
remboursement représentera 2,4 milliard
d'euros par an alors que nous sommes le
second contributeur net au budget de
l'Union notre déficit aggravé nous
expose au risque de sanction par la
commission qui souhaite imposer le
retour aux règles du pacte de stabilité
pourtant notre gouvernement ne pousse
pas au conseil pour développer les
ressources propres à la hauteur
nécessaire loin de là par exemple la
taxe sur le numérique a été abandonné
par peur de représaill américaines de
même la taxe sur les transactions
financières il n'y a enfin toujours pas
d'avancée majeur s'agissant de
l'harmonisation fiscale et d'une assise
commune pour l'impôt sur les sociétés
que fait notre gouver gouvernement au
conseil pour hter la mise en œuvre de
ressources propres suffisant rien que la
taxe sur les GATS femmes pourrait
rapporter jusqu'à 4 milliards par an
vous l'aurez compris faute de ressources
propres le plan de relance va aggraver
la dette des États-membres y compris
celle de la France l'austérité
budgétaire serait donc l'horizon imposé
au peuple européen grande entreprise du
numérique transaction financières
assiette commune d'impôts sur les
sociétés nos citoyens contribuable
attendent de vous que vous fassiez
participer au budget européen ceux qui
profitent de l'Europe et des crris sans
prendre part à l'effort collectif merci
la parole est à présent notre collègue
Éric Boquet pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste kanaki
pour 4 minutes bien merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre mes chers
collègues la réforme du budget européen
est une impérieuse nécessité c'est le
cri des parlementaires européens qui
s'inquiète du devenir des Finances de
l'Union et pour cause le cadre financier
pluriannuel proposé par la Commission
européenne en juin 2023 est au point
mort supplanté par les discussions
autour du conflit au Proche Orient sans
entrer dans les détails la Commission
propose d'amender à la marge le cadre
financier précédent en renforçant des
aides à l'Ukraine la mise en place d'une
plateforme européenne et technologie
stratégiqu dit step un renforcement des
financements de 18 milliards pour faire
face aux migrations et le financement
des traitement des fonctionnaires
européens indexés pourtant face à ces
moyens supplémentaires la contribution
de la France budget de l'Union
européenne diminuerait de 3,3 38
milliards par rapport à la loi de
finance pour 2023 c'est mes chers
collègues dans le jargon budgétaire une
baisse conjoncturelle et j'y vois une
baisse en trompelœil en fait qui sera se
rappeler à nous en temps voulu un
trompelœil d'abord parce que ce sont les
retards de la mise en œuvre si important
de la politique de cohésion ces retards
de déploiement se traduisent par une
baisse des paiements de 37 milliards du
Fond Européen de Développement régional
le FEDER du fond de cohésion du Fond
Social européen le FSE et une baisse de
3 milliards d'euros pour le Fond
Européen agricole pour le développement
rural féader les documents annexés sont
clairs il y aura un rattrapage mes chers
collègues le sentiment anti-européen
fustigant ces institutions est nourri
par son recul par ses tergiversations et
par l'impression que la solidarité
européenne pardon est au point mort un
trompleœil car les ressources
budgétaires consacré au remboursement de
l'emprunt du volet subvention du plan
next duration eu pour la bagatelle et de
390 milliards avait été financé sur la
base d'hypothèse de taux d'intérêt
aujourd'hui dépassé en quelque sorte la
question du financement été mise sous le
tapis l'endettement comme une forme de
fuite en avant ce ne sont donc plus 0,55
% en 2021 à 1,15 en 2027 alors qu'ils
sont déjà supérieurs à 3 % à l'heure
actuelle et que il a des financements
indispensables du Fond Social pour le
climat qui permettrait une transition
écologique socialement juste alors qu'un
nouveau marché carbone hetera les
ménages en matière de transport et sur
le chauffage dans les bâtiments sans
contrepartie sociale la transition
écologique sera veine d'ailleurs les
choses pourraient se compliquer dans 5
ans un certain chercheur estime qu'en
l'état des émissions je cite en 2032 la
Commission devrait engager des
procédures d'infraction contre près de
20 États membres pour se conformer aux
objectifs du pacte vert ce n'est pas les
secousses mais un séisme social qui
devrait se faire jour en vérité c'est au
moment du premier débat sur la directive
ressources propres que vous avez voté
mes chers collègues en février 2021 que
se posait l'avenir financier de l'Union
une contribution sur le plastique pour
sol de tout compte 1,5 milliards de
moins à verser le reste des promesses de
travail si bien qu'en juin 2023 la
commission rend une nouvelle copie avec
des solutions à la marge il faut que la
France revienne sur la règle de
l'unanimité cet impératif pour ne pas
voir le projet européen mourir pour
empêcher les blocages systématiques
passage où en est-on de la taxation des
transactions financières qui pourrait
singulièrement soulager les
contributions des États-membres en
créant une ressource assis sur la
spéculation qui va bon train il y a ce
qui relève des mécanismes
institutionnels et de l'ambition
politique les deux ne vont parfois pas
de paire la Commission propose le
proposait dans la directive sur les
ressources propres que vous avez voté
n'ayez pas la mémoire courte l'impasse
budgétaire est proche il faut
l'escalader au risque de ne mettre en
péril l'Union mon groupe votera contre
ces crédits ces crédit j'ai dit qui
empêche de réaliser l'exigence
climatique du pacte vert et de
concrétiser la cohésion européenne en
l'absence de toute taxation sur le
capital je vous remercie merci la parole
est à présent madameque Girardin pour le
groupe RDSE pour 4
minutes monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre mes chers collègues au détour
d'un seul article ce sont pas loin de 22
milliards d'euros qui seront budgetés
dans ce projet de loi de finance 2024 au
titre de la participation de la France à
l'Union européenne nos collègues
rapporteurs l'ont rappelé la baisse de
cette contribution par rapport à celle
de 2023 n'est pas provisoire au regard
des engagements n'est que provisoire au
regard des engagements à venir que ce
soit sur le plan de de relance européen
ou sur la révision à mi-parcours du
cadre financier plurannuel en cours
l'évolution tendantielle habituellement
la hausse de cette clé de contribution
fait souvent dé bat pour le RDSE
profondément attaché au projet européen
la question ne se pose pas ni sur le
principe ni sur le fond d'ailleurs
s'agissant du principe je rappellerai
que le prélèvement européen est bien
plus qu'un acte financier il est une
déclaration tangible en faveur d'une
Europe résiliente solidaire et
souveraine la gestion collective du
covid le soutien partagé à l'Ukraine et
l'effort cons
concerté de réduction de la dépendance
énergétique en S des illustrations sur
le fond faut-il rappeler que si notre
pays est le deuxième contributeur net il
est aussi depuis toujours l'un des
principaux bénéficiaires des dépenses de
l'Union des dépenses qui irriguent un
bon nombre de nos politiques publiques
qui en particulier nous voulons le noter
le fait sur des secteurs dit
traditionnels je pense bien entendu à la
PAC sans laquelle notre modèle agricole
n'aurait peut-être pas fait sam'amus
structurel pour une un objectif
incontournable de transition écologique
et je n'oublie pas l'importance des
instruments de gestion de crise pour
lesquels on peut bien entendu faire
mieux mais je pense à ce que nous avons
fait pour la pêche qui devrait être
davantage soutenu mais malgré tout nous
sommes intervenus ou l'Europe est
intervenu pour parvenir à être bien sûr
plus durable que ce soit dans les
territoires des régions côtières ou
encore dans les régions ultra péri que
pour autant tous nos concitoyens
européens ne mesurent pas les efforts
portés par les institutions européennes
pour relever à la fois les crises et les
grands défis de long terme que chacun
des États-membres ne pourrait pas
résoudre seul depuis 2 ans pour un total
de 490 milliards d'euros le Conseil
européen a validé 25 plans de relance et
de résilience le fameux plan national
pour la reprise et résilience dans celui
des Pays-Bas en 2022 à cet égard la
menace d'un référendum dans ce pays sur
leur appartenance à l'Union européenne
devenue très preignante avec la percée
hier au législatif du parti de liberté
de gwielders doit nous interroger est-ce
ça manque de pédagogie oui le règlement
de Dublin n'est pas parfait oui l'agence
Frontex n'est pas for n'a pas forcément
les moyens de ses missions mais quel
état-membre peut prétendre mieux régler
seul l'immense défi migratoire qui est
devant nous il n'y a qu'à observer le
Royaume-Uni se débattre sur cette
question depuis 3 ans alors ah ça manque
de moyens sans doute aussi mais pourrait
en faire plus que les 1824 milliards
d'euros du CPF de
2021-2027 additionner des moyens du plan
next génération
UE autre élément que je souhaitais
soulever la question de la dette de
l'Union européenne qui refait surface
avec une échéance de début de
remboursement à horizon 2028 va-t-on
assister une nouvelle fois à la pression
des frugau pour un retour à l'orthodoxie
budgétaire un axe qui fragiliserait une
reprise européenne déjà bien à tonne la
seule issue mon groupe l'a toujours
défondu c'est celle de la recherche de
ressources propres allant chercher
l'argent là où il se trouve je me
réjouis de voir que la Commission
européenne ait présenté en juin dernier
les projets de nouvelles ressources
propres qui pourraiit alimenter le
budget européen à hauteur de 36
milliards d'euros par an oui Aué isme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières oui
au levier fondé sur l'excédent brut des
entreprises je n'oublie pas l'accord
multilatéral de l'OCDE G20 sur la
fiscalité internationale arraché après
des années de lutte pour conclure un
reproche tout cela est bien long bien
trop long le Conseil européen avance à
petit pas au risque de voir le paysage
politique européen se fracturer encore
un peu plus au fil des années c'est
pourquoi notre groupe votera l'article
33 pour une Europe que nous voulons
toujours plus solidaire et plus
convainquante merci la parole est à
présent notre collègue Jean-Baptiste
Lemoine pour 5
minutes bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
le président madame la ministre mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs sénatrices
chers collègues point de suspense
inutile le groupe RDPI votera
unanimement en faveur de cette article
33 de la ha finances pour 2024 un
article peut-être un peu méconnu de la
part de nos concitoyens mais qui est
fondamental à tous égards pour notre
pays et pour l'Union européenne alors
c'est un vote pour qui est motivé par
une conviction européenne profonde et
puis aussi par une volonté de cohérence
politique on est vcéralement attaché à
cette construction européenne et nous
pensons que l'avenir de notre pays il
est indéiablement et indissociablement
lié à la capacité et bien de cette union
à
affronter de solidairement les défis
économiques sécuritaires énergétiqu que
écologique et d'ailleurs cette
construction elle est pas exnio j'ai en
tête ce que disait Denis drougemont ce
grand penseur qui évoquait justement
l'Europe unie qui n'est pas un expédient
moderne économique ou politique mais
bien un idéal que qui est approuvé
depuis 1000 an par tous les meilleurs
esprits ceux qui ont vu loin et parlant
de de cohérence
politique nous sommes véritablement des
défenseurs de ces deux lettres u e Union
européenne au moment où elles sont
souvent le Bou émissaire mode de
certains on l' encore vu avec les
élections effectivement il y a quelques
jours aux Pays-Bas autour du sujet
migratoire mais justement la révision du
cadre financier pluriannuel il prévoit
le renforcement du budget de l'UE à
hauteur de 18 milliards d'euros pour
faire face à la dimension interne et
externe de ces migrations au partenariat
avec des pays tiersclés donc c'est bien
aussi à cette échelle-là et bien qu'on a
les moyens de pouvoir traiter les
racines profondes fond et bien de ce
sujet de la migration encore une fois
cohérence politique parce que nous avons
toujours plaidé pour effectivement aussi
un changement de dimension cette union
européenne une Union européenne plus
stratégique qui a des moyens renforcés
et souvenons-nous de l'énergie qu'il a
fallu déployer que le chef de l'État a
dû déployer pour obtenir ce plan de
relance européen là aussi c'est un vrai
changement de dimension avec aussi pour
partie un recours à l'emprunt mais grâce
à ça nous sommes une Europe qui n'est
plus une Europe de naïf euh nous nous
nous avons les moyens de nous doter d'un
certain nombre d'instruments pour être
dans la compétition mondiale
euh au premier rang et la France certes
va contribuer à hauteur de 21,6
milliards d'euros en 2024 mais combien
va-t-elle justement pouvoir agir en
terme d'effet levierers c'est
considérable regardons le le plan de
relance français les 100 milliards
d'euros et bien il y en a 40 milliards
qui proviennent euh de l'Union
européenne et tout cela avec d'ailleurs
une une dimension une visée euh verte
puisqueil y a la cible des 30 % d'action
climat euh donc on voit qu'on est aussi
dans une logique de transformation qui
est tout à fait opportune et puis il y a
ce qui se voit dans le budget et il y a
ce qui se voit pas parce que
naturellement il y a énormément de
dépenses européennes qui contribue aussi
au meilleur fonctionnement de nos
territoires de notre pays on pense à la
politique agricole commune on pense à un
certain nombre de fonds de de cohésion
et je veux dire que il y a de ce points
de vue là des enjeux de communication
qui sont effectiv
très important pour que tout à chacun
voit que l'Europe prête chez lui c'est
une réalité qui est tangible qui est
accessible et qu'aucun canton de France
et bien n'échappe justement aux vertus
de ces crédits européens et puis je veux
saluer aussi dans la proposition de
révision du cadre financier pluriannuel
et bien le le renforcement de l'action
au côté de l'Ukraine avec la facilité de
50 milliards d'euros la plateforme
européenne des technologies stratégiques
effectivement la fameuse step qui nous
permet d'aller sur les technologies
critiques donc vous le voyez l'adoption
de ce budget est essentielle pour nous
donner les moyens d'influer plus
efficacement sur la marche du monde et
de relever tous ensemble les défis de
long terme je vous
remercie
merci la parole est à présent à Madame
Laurence bonne secrétaire d'État chargé
de
l'Europe
pardon monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président de la commission des finances
madame la vice-présidente de la
Commission des Affaires européenne
monsieur le rapporteur spécial et
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs je
voudrais d'abord saluer la qualité du
rapport de Monsieur Jean-Marie mon
rapporteur spécial de la mission
participation de la France au budget de
l'Union européenne et du rapporteur
général ainsi que la qualité des débats
en commission des finances le 31 octobre
dernier c'est évidemment toujours un
plaisir de se retrouver devant vous et
pour vous demander aujourd'hui au nom du
gouvernement d'autoriser le prélèvement
sur les recettes de l'État au profit de
l'Union européenne pour l'année
2024 comme vous l'avez souligné
s'éleverit pour l'année 2024 à 21,6
milliards d'euros c'est il a un montant
inférieur à celui de 2023 il est très
proche de celui que nous connaissions
avant la pandémie du
covid en tant que deuxème contributeur
au budget de l'Union notre contribution
est évidemment clé pour la mise en œuvre
de l'accord entre conseil et Parlement
européen sur le budget
2024 et plus largement et plus gravement
je crois que alors que la France et
l'Europe font face à une somme inédite
de défis
notre contribution française est
essentielle pour permettre à l'Union
européenne d'avancer et de répondre à
nos défis prioritaires que vous avez
cité crise géopolitique enjeu migratoire
défi de la transition
écologique et la contribution française
n'a d'autre vocation que de permettre la
réalisation de ce
projet alors tout d'abord monsieur le
rapporteur spécial et messsieurs les
sénateurs cap fernic vous avez mentionné
la révision en cours du cadre financier
pluriannuel et c'est bien dans ce cadre
que nous allons assurer la pérénisation
d'aide à l'Ukraine avec la proposition
de facilité Ukraine sur la période
2024-2027 à ce sujet vous avez vous êtes
inquiété des amendements il n'y aura pas
d'amendement au projet de drit de
finance pour le prélèvement sur sur
recette parce que les négociations du
cadre financier pluriannuel sont
toujours en cours et à date il y a trop
d'incertitude sauf une qui est que
l'effet sera l'effet de l'accord sera
mineur sur le budget
2024 vous m'avez aussi interrogé sur les
priorités du CF de la révision du CFP je
viens de le dire l'Union pardon le
soutien à l'Ukraine est la première des
priorités et je rappelle à cet égard que
les prêts que nous faisons à l'Ukraine
sont garantis par le budget de l'Union
européenne deuxièmement le budget
européen permettra aussi de financer
notre réponse européenne au défis
migratoires parce que ces financements
doivent nous permettre la mise en œuvre
du pacte sur la migration et l'asile
pour laquelle un accord doit
impérativement être trouvé avant la fin
de la législature actuel du Parlement
européen ces financements doivent nous
permettre de renforcer aussi aussi nos
partenariats avec les paystiers
notamment d'origine et de transit des
flux
migratoires je voudrais aussi rappeler
ce que notre contribution au budget
européen veut dire en
pratique parce que notre contribution
permet à l'Europe de disposer des moyens
nécessaires à la mise en œuvre des
politiques communes qui agissent
directement au service de notre pays et
de nos citoyens et je pense d'abord à la
politique agricole mais aussi au
programme pour la jeunesse ou au
financement de la transition
écologique avec le budget européen nous
finançons une politique agricole commune
et vous êtes nombreux à l'avoir rappelé
nous sommes de loin le premier
bénéficiaire de la PAC et je rappelle
que la PAC représente 31 % du budget de
l'Union européenne et assure à la France
près de 9,5 milliards de retours par an
donc financer le PSR c'est aussi
financer notre agric culture et c'est
mieux qu'un
Rabet puisque nous en sommes les
premiers contributeurs et pour mémoire
je rappelle à certains que c'est
l'Allemagne qui paye deux fois plus et
qui contribue à 25 % du budget européen
et qui reçoit deux fois moins que la
France en net ça s'appelle quelque part
la
solidarité avec le budget nous
renforçons aussi la résilience de notre
économie notamment la politique de
cohésion qui contribue comme aussi le
plan de relance qui ont été adopté lors
de la crise sanitaire je rappelle aussi
ici que le plan de relance européen
bénéficie à la France à hauteur de 40,3
milliards de subventions jusqu'en 2026
et que la Commission vient de verser
vient d'approuver vendredi 27 novembre
un montant de 10,3 milliards au titre de
la 2uxème demande de décaissement qui
sera versé avant la fin de l'année ces
financements vous n'ignorez pas
messieurs sénateur ferernque et Arnaud
contribueront largement à accélérer la
transition verte en
France plus largement le budget européen
est un levier essentiel pour atteindre
nos objectifs de souveraineté européenne
comme l'a rappelé le président de la
République lors du sommet de Versailles
et comme vient de le rappeler à
l'instant monsieur le sénateur Lemoine
que je veux
remercier la mise en œuvre de l'agenda
de versaill doit permettre de réduire
nos dépendances dans tous les secteurs
critiques et à travers des objectifs
chiffrés à horizon 2030 de renforcer la
production européenne et la puissance
européenne nous pouvons nous réjouir à
ce titre de l'accord obtenu en trilogue
le 13 novembre dernier sur l'une des
législations issues de l'agenda de
Versailles le critical romaterial Act je
voudrais rappeler ici qu'avec 440
millions de
citoyens la France à travers l'Europe p
beaucoup plus dans le monde quand il
s'agit de négocier des accords
commerciaux stratégiques ou des
investissements stratégiques ou un
critical rematériel Act qu'elle ne le
serait toute
seule
ensuite j'ai entendu vos remarques et
inquiétude sur notre capacité à trouver
de nouvelles ressources propres vous
avez été nombreux à les souligner et
parmi vous monsieur le rapporteur
spécial mesdames les sénatrices Girardin
et BL excat et aussi madame la sénatrice
Lavarde la France est favorable vous le
savez à la mise en place de ces
nouvelles ressources sur le plan
politique elles vont nous permettre de
sortir de la logique délétaire d'examen
des taux de retour et sur le plan
financier elles permettront d'éviter un
ressaut de nos contributions nationales
pour rembourser le plan de relance
européen la présidence espagnole
poursuit en ce moment les travaux les
nouvelles ressources et notamment celles
qui concerernent les Ets et la taxe et
le mécanisme d'ajustement carbone aux
frontières sont estimé en moyenne à 36
milliards d'euros par an à partir de
2028 ce qui sera suffisant pour le
remboursement du plan de relance et pour
le fond social pour le
climat je voudrais également
euh je crois nous féliciter que la
France soit leader dans la construction
d'une Europe puissante et souveraine
qu'elle est à cœur de défendre ses
intérêt et que elle a su montrer son
rôle essentiel au cœur des crises
notamment comme vous l'avez rappelé pour
le plan de relance next generation
eu et je voudrais ici à Monsieur durx
vous dire que vous me peinez car je
crois que vous cachez à vos électeurs
les enjeux auxquels nous avons à faire
face qui ont été rappelés d'ailleurs par
plusieurs membres de cette icycle les
menaces russes l'ingérence chinoise le
repli possible des États-Unis et donc
les bénéfices en terme de sécurité que
nous avons en étant plus fort dans
l'Union européenne car la défense ne
peut-être que nationale nous le voyons
aujourd'hui les bénéfices également en
terme de commerce car à 440 millions de
citoyens nous sommes bien plus forts
qu'à 60 millions les bénéfices en terme
de climat parce que la transition
énergétique ne peut pas se faire toute
seule elle serait à la fois plus
difficile et plus coûteuse et j'en passe
et comme l'a dit monsieur le sénateur
Capu l'Europe est un levier pour nous
rendre plus fort plus souverain et plus
puissant voilà je me réjouis que
l'examen de notre contribution au budget
européen soit l'occasion de nous
permettre d'avoir ce débat démocratique
sur les priorités européennes et sur la
manière dont la France y répond et y
contribue et je vous
remercie merci beaucoup je vais mettre
au voix l'article
33 qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté mes
chers collègues par lettre en date de ce
jour le gouvernement demande
l'inscription à l'ordre du jour du lundi
18 décembre sous réserve de sa
transmission par l'Assemblée nationale
de la proposition de loi visant à
prolonger en 2024 l'utilisation des
titres restaurants pour des achats de
produits alimentaires non directement
consommables il demande également
l'inversion de l'ordre d'examen de la
lecture des conclusions de la commission
mixte paritaire sur la proposition
visant à revaloriser le métier de
secrétaire de mairie et de celle sur la
proposition de loi visant à améliorer
l'accès aux soins par l'engagement
territorial des professionnels prévu le
même jour en outre il complète l'ordre
du jour du jeudi 21 décembre le matin
avec l'inscription sous réserve de leur
dépôt de la lecture des conclusions de
la commission mixte paritaire ou de la
nouvelle lecture sur la proposition de
loi relative au titre restaurant acte
est donné de cette demande en
conséquence pour ce texte nous pourrions
fixer le délai limite pour le dépôt des
amendements en séance le vendredi 15
décembre à 12h et le délai limite
d'inscription des orateurs dans la
discussion générale sur ce texte le même
jour à 15h par ailleurs les explications
de vote et le vote sur la proposition de
loi Visante à prolonger en 2024 le
dispositif exceptionnel d'utilisation
des titres restaurants pour soutenir le
pouvoir d'achat serait retiré de l'ordre
du jour du mardi 12 décembre y a-t-il
des
observations il n'y en a pas il il en
est ainsi décidé mes chers collègues je
vais lever la séance prochaine séance
vendredi 24 novembre 2023 à 16h pour la
suite de l'examen des articles de la
première partie du projet de loi de
finance pour 2024 la séance est
levée